hey this is a pressure Locker can you
calculate the perimeter of these
composite rectilinear shapes these
problems caused a stir when they were
assigned to ten year olds in England
some parents could not solve these
problems and took their complaints to
Facebook one parent even said these
problems are impossible to solve can you
figure them out to get started I'll
define a couple of terms a rectilinear
shape is one whose edges all meet at
right angles each interior angle is
either equal to 90 degrees or 270
degrees a composite shape is one that
can be broken down into simpler shapes
like triangles rectangles and so on
let's calculate the perimeter of these
composite rectilinear shapes starting
with the shape on the Left we are only
given the dimensions of two of the edges
the perimeter will be equal to these
lengths plus the lengths of the unknown
edges while we don't know the lengths of
these edges we can figure out their
total length will color the unknown
horizontal edges in orange and the
unknown vertical edges in green we need
to figure out the total length of the
orange pieces and the green pieces we
can do this using a clever principle we
can consider the total length of the
horizontal edges and see that these two
orange edges will have a total length of
10 similarly we can look at the vertical
edges and we can see that combined they
will have a total length equal to 12 so
we can deduce the total length of the
unknown orange edges is equal to 10 and
the total length of the unknown vertical
edges which are in green are equal to 12
we now have enough information to
calculate the perimeter which will be
equal to
for now let's solve the second problem
we know the length of some of the edges
and we need to compute the length of the
unknown edges while we don't know the
length of each individual edge we will
again consider the length the total
length of these unknown edges this
problem will be a little bit trickier
we'll get started by calculating the
horizontal edges which we'll color in
orange together these unknown horizontal
edges will have a total length equal to
the known horizontal edge of 9 so these
orange edges will all add up to 9 the
vertical edges are a little bit trickier
because they overlap so what we'll do is
we'll try and count it without
overlapping we have one vertical edge
and now we'll continue this vertical
edge without overlapping together these
two vertical edges will have a total
length equal to 11 there's one edge one
port part of the edge which we haven't
considered
will color this in blue and we can see
from the diagram that this will have it
length equal to two we now have enough
information to calculate the total
length of the unknown edges we
substitute these values in and we can
therefore calculate the perimeter is
equal to 44 did you figure out these
problems thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Locker and if you
liked this video please check out my
books there links in the video
description